in a meeting last week to discuss
immigration policy you all know
president Trump referred to Haiti and
African countries as [ __ ] countries
and a lot of people yeah thought this
was it's a children show here now
thought this was crude disrespectful a
lot of people saying this is borderline
racist if not race it's pretty race
slimy to lose border line I think you
can lose border line I'm gonna keep it
in for now
all right anyway according to witnesses
at the meeting the president singled out
the country of Haiti
in particular saying why do we need more
Haitians take them out that is
apparently a quote now I have no idea
what the president has against the
people of Haiti but if the president
doesn't like them they must be lovely
people they really I mean it's just yeah
which is why which is why later this
week I'm gonna fly to Haiti visit with
them and say hello try to make some
friends over there it's going to be our
Conan in Haiti show
yeah
I was thinking about it and I'm sure I'm
gonna love Haiti mainly because Trump
hates it so much you see what I've
noticed is whenever that guy hates
something I wind up loving it for
example I look these all up and you're
true Trump hates exercise right
I enjoy exercise Trump hates reading I
love reading I read all the time
Trump's thinks Meryl Streep is overrated
I love Meryl Streep's work I love her
and everything Trump hates working for
more than an hour a day I love working
exactly Trump hates when women reject
him I love my teens and 20s those are my
best and 30s
and mid 40s mid 40s I was married at the
time he got weird anyway Trump hates
patiently listened to people he
considers beneath him I've worked with
Andy for 25 years
I love being beneath you Trump hates
women over 40 people often mistake me
for a woman over 40 yeah finally Trump
doesn't think much of Haiti well that
could only mean one thing I'm gonna love
going to Haiti later this week be sure
be sure to follow our trip in real time
you can watch what I'm up to in real
time at facebook.com slash team cocoa
instagram.com / team Coco and
twitter.com slash Conan O'Brien or if
you're my parents
I'll send you telegrams okay
you